what's happening there reject nation if
you've clicked on this video because
you're excited for multiverse of madness
leave a like that would be so
appreciated so we got a few things to
discuss today first off downloaded this
video i haven't seen it yet but
apparently it's patrick stewart perhaps
confirming that he's actually in
multiverse of madness enough for the
shannon goodness i wanted to talk about
how this could actually open up the door
for hugh jackman to return as wolverine
i have a little bit of a theory greg's
been putting out some theories lately
and i got a small one that i want to
share with you guys of how it could
actually work and not discredit the
events of logan
that's
have i got your curiosity all right
let's go into this
[Music]
the commercial comes on for a marvel
movie in which someone kind of sounds
like you how quickly does your phone go
off and is there any part of you that
thinks
i really just want to watch the game i i
i wasn't prepared for this well i had my
phone turned off as it happened and so i
didn't hear anything it wasn't until the
next morning when i woke up and looked
at my phone and found that i had been
bombarded with the responses and that my
pr people had sent me reactions that
they had uh they had detailed and passed
on to me and um
i actually didn't recognize my own voice
it sounded different
whether i had a cold or something at the
time
but i was astonished it's very all they
saw was the back of my shoulder and i
think my earlobe nothing else that there
would have been so many connections made
um but i it it uh it pleased me
so you could take alex's look like i
just got the goddamn scoop
he's gotta wait for the exact right time
to drop this information
he just said did you recognize my whole
voice right there yeah that's pretty
much him confirming it maybe kevin feige
was like you don't
you don't have to deny it man you're in
the the trailer that's the pretty good
conference it's the reason we used to we
don't want people not to see it
it's fine you don't have to wait we're
far past alfred molina now you're a
veteran you can do what you want it's
not some andrew garfield situation
you're here to replicate the level of
multiversal hype that the spider-man
trailers got out of the older spider-man
villains like please tell people you're
in the movie interesting medium we're
living in now where we just don't
believe anyone anymore that's pretty
much a confirmation but guys listen we
already knew that patrick stewart was
gonna be in here let's talk about
wolverine really quick now there's been
a lot of reports coming out as of late
there might be a wolverine who shows up
in doctor strange multiverse of madness
but it will be a different actor playing
wolverine it could be the new version
for the mcu it could just be a variant
from one of the many multiverses i think
if they were to bring in a wolverine i
don't know which one would be more
acceptable for audiences like should it
be the the new this is our way of
introducing you will varane is like is
it too much to do in this new movie to
like here's where we're establishing our
brand new wolverine amidst everything
when the main takeaway should be you
know all the other cameos you know it
should be scarlet witch
all right like dr strange in the main
story i saw some people passing this
around and i couldn't quite find the
actual source of this but it got me
thinking of how it could actually work
because i started thinking about the
timelines with logan and doctor strange
multiverse and madness i saw people
saying hugh jackman said he would return
to patrick stewart returns and i've been
like googling trying to find like where
did hugh jackman say this and why do
people believe this i can't actually
find that piece of information so if you
guys find it if you want to link it in
the comments that would be very much
appreciated because i personally can't
find that piece of information but then
i started thinking about wait a minute
if we look at the events of patrick
stewart in logan that movie took place
in 2029 specifically and there's been a
lot of theories like is patrick stewart
charles xavier is he actually you know a
variant is he from the x-men animated
show is just some different is he from
the fox x-men universe seems like the
most exciting thing you would pull is
pull them from the fox x-men universe
but will that undo the events of logan
no because doctor strange multiverse of
madness is reported to take place in
2023 so when you're looking at the
actual years like you could actually see
a scenario because there's such a time
jump in the x-men movies from the last
time you're with charles xavier
specifically patrick stewart to when you
see him in logan where he's got that
brain degenerative disease that's caused
him to have these effects where he's
like killed some of the x-men off and a
bunch of people as well including you
know so he's at this really tomorrow's
time in his life so i'm like whoa you
could even if that theory lines up of
that a lot of people have now shared
what if there was like a scarlet witch
or wanda event that happened in the fox
x-men universe that we just didn't get a
seat what if something like that
actually took like repercussions or
damage to him in what occurs in logan
but then again you know it's like
if
patrick steward you know gets offed in
multiverse and madness then i'm like
that totally throws all that
yeah yeah absolutely i mean i do it's a
compelling theory because i can see a
way especially if you don't mess with
the timeline yeah where you were i feel
like that would be the best the only way
for for me that fans would accept a both
the return of of patrick stewart xavier
and the return of hugh jackman's logan
would be yeah it's in a way that is not
only respectful to the current timeline
but that maybe even also has some kind
of clever way of embellishing that
existing timeline and feeling like it's
not only a fun inclusion but also
essential and i wonder if maybe they
might do both as a means of tempering
that you can get a little bit with hugh
jackman have him be you know the the
requisite sort of uh fist pumping
appearance in the mcu we've all been
hoping for but then also take it as the
opportunity to do like a low-key screen
test for whoever you might be
considering to be the next logan or
wolverine and two i mean i personally
have been sitting here wondering what if
we get more than one of some of these
people what if they're teasing us with a
patrick stewart and then the idea that
you know if that quote you mentioned is
true that hugh jackman would come back
if he's involved what other versions of
them might we see and how many i feel
like you know it's not the point so
we're not gonna see a million but we
could see a couple you know especially
as dr strange traverses and especially
as he deals with the illuminati who are
clearly you know some of the most
powerful beings in each of their
respective universes and probably carry
that across some of their variants i
feel like yeah there's a broad spectrum
of possibility there's a whole lot you
can do because yeah the the common
theory now is that you know what if
there were mutants already in the mcu
yeah new rockstars totally did their
video first right yeah like that's the
common theory that's been going around
so this wouldn't be like a a combination
of the fox universe and marvel cinematic
universe going forward yeah we would
just like bring back the mutants that
were just supposed to be in the marvel
cinematic universe you could still like
send back logan and patrick stewart so
that way their movie still plays out
yeah yeah yeah they're still relegated
they still exist leaves them on their
timeline don't do something where they
like snatch wolverine right as he's
about to die
or something like that yeah and be like
you know we own you again do something
where you can place them back when
everything is concluded by the end you
know but that's just a little side
thought that i had yeah there's been
reports about like hugh jackman meeting
with kevin feige which i believe that
kevin feige with everything they've been
bringing back i could totally see kevin
feige just being like dude what do i got
to do to get you i won't do anything
like we have your prices we already got
the original spideys if we can get you
back oh my god this movie will break the
box office all over again there's been
reports about him trying to get him back
for secret wars specifically which
actually seems more likely than for
actually multiverse of madness you know
i'm not eliminating hugh jackman
returning for a cameo especially because
they did work together on the first
x-men movie i think that should be a
good full circle but guys what do you
think about all this leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit
that like button and we will catch you
guys soon